les stars du football vont à nouveau
fouler cette pelouse deux ans après
l'euro 2016 et la venue de l'équipe de
russie croissy-sur-seine sera la seule
ville yvelinoise accueillir des sessions
d'entraînement des équipes nationales
pour la coupe du monde féminine
une décision prise en avril dernier par
la fifa et le comité d'organisation
c'est une surprise non c'est la
continuation de ce qu'on avait déjà
engagé avec l'euro 2016 et puis l'équipe
d'angleterre l'avait appris qui est venu
s'entraîner ici
donc effectivement on avait candidaté
pour la coupe du monde au total quatre
équipes nationales vont s'entraîner sur
le site à partir du 3 juin l'afrique du
sud l'ecosse et surtout la dream team
américaine trois fois vainqueur de
l'édition est tenant du titre
les supporters pourront également voir
un entraînement de l'équipe de france
hôte de la compétition l'équipe de
france est premier numéro un mondial
l'équipe des états unis oui ça bug de
convenir bien sûr escale intéressant
c'est qu'il y aura des entraînements
ouverts
donc on pourra faire profiter nos jeunes
sportifs ils pourront côtoyer des
sportifs de haut niveau et ça c'est
aussi très important pour moi je pense
qu'on n'a pas de faire monter la sauce
elles montrent déjà rien que de savoir
que les ya un seul entraînement ouvert
pour l'équipe de france et qui se
passera à croissy on aura là du monde
largement autant qu'on en veut comme
pour l'euro 2016 les équipes évolueront
principalement sur le terrain d'honneur
pendant les sessions d'entraînement dans
le gymnase on retrouvera les vestiaires
ainsi qu'une salle de fitness pour
travailler le renforcement musculaire
un espace sera également dédié à la
presse les aménagements tout effet type
euro 2016 donc a pas de différence si ce
n'est un stade qui est un petit peu plus
large que celui de l'euro 2016 pour
promouvoir dans la ville le football
féminin et cette huitième coupe du monde
des animations seront organisées dans la
ville de croissy sur seine avec
notamment la mise en place d'une fan
zone derrière le terrain d'entraînement
pour suivre les matchs jusqu'au 7
juillet